I'm Seri your virtual assistant
I'm Seri whoa is that a dude yes you can
change series voice to a male voice and
you've been able to do it for the last
three years but how often do you hear
this I'm Seri the majority of our
artificially intelligent voice
assistants are female
there's Amazon's Alexa hi there
Microsoft's Cortana hi there party
people
Google's assistant yoyoyo and yes Siri
what's up y'all but why so many females
probably because women are the best
that's not true ok it's true
ok you two there are a few reasons why
we see more women BOTS and it doesn't
really have anything to do with the fact
that women have historically been
personal assistants good because my
boyfriend is Tony Stark's secretary oh
so you're not single ok man but you take
number one gender is important because
without one people do not like to talk
to us robots at all experts and studies
have found that if robots are given
gender cues it will make it easier for
humans to relate to them even without
them humans will assign a he or a she
pronoun plus robotic voices are a dead
giveaway they tend to be either female
or male there are no real genderless
options and number two females are seen
as more welcoming warm and nurturing by
both men and women a 2011 study out of
Indiana University found that both men
and women say they prefer a female voice
Microsoft and Amazon also found the same
in their research but that doesn't mean
there aren't and won't be man bots male
voices may be preferred for certain
subject areas for instance Domino's
decided to give Daum its Pizza ordering
voice assistant a male voice and persona
[Music]
the company knows it's app is primarily
used by younger men the problem with
giving gender to robots is that some of
the problematic stereotypes can carry
over to one study out of Stanford
University showed that when being taught
about computers both men and women
prefer hearing from a male voice
but when hearing about love and
relationships they preferred a female
voice that's why it's important for us
to have both male and female voices and
to have both options to choose from pick
me pick me pick me dude calm down
unfortunately you can't change the voice
of Alexa Google assistant or Cortana but
if you have an iPhone I challenge you to
go into settings then Siri and change
the voice - I just don't get this whole
gender thing